999 DAYS:
On February 25, 2020, Bob Chapek was promoted
to being CEO of Walt Disney.
Disney was doing better than ever before.
They had just released Frozen 2 a few months
ago and it was breaking box office records
left and right.
Meanwhile, Disney Plus had just been launched
3 months ago and it was growing faster than
even Disney could imagine.
People were watching movies more than ever,
traveling more than ever, and Covid was just
something that you read about on the news.
But, just 17 days after his promotion, the
United States would enter a national lockdown
and enter one of the most unprecedented times
in history.
Overnight, all Disney Parks shutdown, no one
was watching Disney movies in theaters, and
Disney couldn’t even produce their films
in person.
Disney had entered one of the worst crises
in its history and the man at the helm had
been there for a whopping 17 days.
Over the next two years, Disney would experience
some of their lowest lows and some of their
highest highs.
Disney Plus would rocket to over 100 million
subscribers putting Netflix to shame.
But at the same time, their multi hundred
million dollar parks would be completely deserted
like some wasteland.
Despite the glorious highs and terrible lows,
it seemed like Disney was overall on the right
track.
By mid 2021, Disney stock was setting new
all time highs, crossing over $200 billion
in market cap.
But all of this would change in 2022.
The first signs of a recession could be seen
over the horizon and as people pulled back
on spending, Disney would be hit harder than
the pandemic.
Day after day, Disney would put in new 52
week low, new 52 week low, new 52 week low.
In fact, they would return to their pandemic
lows.
And it turned out that Disney plus wasn’t
nearly as successful as the media had led
us to believe.
Subscriber numbers were plummeting, the platform
was losing billions, and there were even signs
that there may have been some accounting fraud.
Obviously, shareholders were furious and at
the end of 999 days, it was decided that Bob
Chapek had done more harm than good.
And in November of 2022, Bob Chapek would
be fired from being Disney’s CEO.
To rub salt in the wound, his replacement
would be his predecessor Bob Iger, something
that Disney fans would celebrate.
So, here’s Bob Chapek’s tumultuous 999
days at the top and why he was really fired
from the top job.
DISNEY+ FRAUD (ALLEGEDLY):
Jumping straight into it, Disney allegedly
discovered that Bob Chapek was cooking the
books to hide the massive losses of Disney+.
It’s not surprising why he would do this.
He had just taken over as CEO during one of
the worst periods of the company’s history.
And if he wanted to stick around and impress
shareholders, he had to put up impressive
numbers.
But, that was nearly impossible when half
of your business is shut down and the other
half is charging super low subscription fees
just to get people in the door.
So, Chapek allegedly turned to the good old
fudge the numbers and hope no one notices.
Honestly, it was quite clever what he did.
He didn’t just pull numbers out of thin
air or make up numbers.
Instead, he would simply rearrange some expenses
to make certain parts of the business look
better than they really were.
The best example of this was with two TV series
called The Mysterious Benedict Society and
Doogie Kamealoha MD.
The production cost of these series is not
known, but it was likely in the tens of millions.
If we call it $50 million each, we have a
total production cost of about $100 million,
and there’s also marketing on top of that,
so quite a sizable expense.
But, Chapek allegedly found a clever way to
offload this cost from Disney+.
You see, he would air these shows on the Disney
Channel slightly before airing them on Disney+.
This way he could write off the marketing
and production expenses of the show as a Disney
channel expense as opposed to a Disney+ expense.
So, instead of costing $50 million each, it
appeared that they only cost $20 or $30 million.
This might not sound like a big deal.
I mean as far as we know, he was marking down
the right numbers.
He was just clevely spreading the cost across
Disney’s various media sectors.
But, while clever, this is also extremely
misleading.
Investors are suddenly led to believe that
these shows achieved an extraordinary ROI
in terms of cost vs viewership leading them
to approve not so great choices.
For example, this tactic made it seem like
launching movies on Disney+ was more worth
it than it really was.
If a $10 million show was able to garner this
much watch time, imagine what a $150 million
flagship movie could bring in.
The truth is not much.
While streaming plaforms are a great way to
earn recurring revenue on movies that have
already had their run in theaters, it’s
a terrible way to monetize new releases.
But, due to potential funny business, the
board and investors weren’t exactly aware
of this and they would allow for movies like
Soul, Disenchanted, and Hocus Pocus 2 to directly
launch on Disney+.
And given that Chapek couldn’t do any slight
of hand with these big name films, it didn’t
take long for investors to realize the truth
about Disney+.
And, let’s just say Disney is now taking
the exact opposite approach when it comes
to bringing movies to Disney+.
With Avatar 2, for example, Disney hasn’t
even provided a release Disney+ release timeframe.
It’s rumored though that it wont come out
till July or 7 months after the initial release.
If Chapek didn’t allegedly play with the
numbers, maybe executives could have come
to this conclusion way quicker like Universal
Studios did with James Bond No Time To Die,
but instead they ended up releasing big budget
films on Disney+ and losing a bunch of money.
Not only is Chapek’s supposed actions misleading,
but in court, it could be argued to be securities
fraud.
After all, misleading investors is against
SEC rules and regulation, but that’s not
where the story ends as Disney+ wasn’t the
only place where some funny business may have
occurred either.
DISNEY PARK FRAUD (ALLEGEDLY):
According to whistleblower Sandy Kuba, Disney
was also cooking the books with their Disney
Parks for years well before Chapek tookover
as CEO.
But, that doesn’t mean that Chapek is in
the clear because guess what Chapek’s job
was before he became CEO?
Well, he was the chairman of Disney Parks
and Resorts since 2015, so it doesn’t seem
like the Disney+ thing was his first offense.
According to Sandy Kuba, Disney was religiously
employing accounting tricks to overstate park
revenues.
Here are some of the tricks that Disney allegedly
leveraged.
You know how sometimes you can get gift cards
for discounted prices?
For example, you might be able to get a $500
gift card for $395 or something.
Well, Disney regularly sells gift cards for
discounts, but instead recording the amount
that customers actually paid for the gift
card, Disney would allegedly just record the
face value of the giftcard.
And when you’re talking about giftcards
that are regularly discounted by 20%, you’re
constantly overstating you’re giftcard revenue
by 20%.
This wasn’t the only gift card trick Disney
had up their sleeve either.
Whenever they gave out free gift cards to
angry customers, well that was apparently
counted as earned revenue as well.
Also, Disney would supposedly count the revenue
of each gift card twice, once when it was
purchased and once when it was used.
It seems like some of these tricks didn’t
just apply to gift cards either.
It appears that Disney was regularly was regularly
marking down all sorts of complimentary items
as earned revenue.
For example, let’s say you booked a hotel
with Disney and received a complimentary round
of golf that’s valued at a $100.
Disney would apparently mark this down as
earned revenue even though you didn’t pay
anything for it.
Also, it’s not like someone was manually
making these changes on the fly.
These tricks were apparently baked into the
software itself making it easy to systematically
overstate revenue by billions of dollars and
nearly impossible to detect without being
an insider.
Sandy would of course try to sort out these
issues internally at first.
She tried contacting senior executives and
the auditing team, but they obviously didn’t
do anything other than threaten her.
They informed her that if she reported her
concerns about the company’s practices elsewhere,
Disney would consider it retaliation against
the company.
Honestly, it would’ve been in Sandy’s
best interest to just keep quiet, but she
would decide to do the brave thing and report
it to the SEC.
I don’t think you’d be surprised to hear
that she would be fired shortly after the
SEC filing was made.
It’s not clear what exactly the SEC has
been doing with this case since then, but
it’s definitely not anything notable.
So, for all we know, Disney could still be
leveraging such tactics to this day.
Also, according to Sandy, the worst of it
was during the 2008 financial crisis when
Disney may have overstated their revenues
by as much as $6 billion.
For perspective, Disney’s total park revenue
in 2009 was $10.6 billion which means that
as much as 60% of this revenue may have been
fraudulent.
With that being said, we just crossed an even
worse period for Disney parks in 2020 and
2021, so who knows how much trickery may have
been happening behind the scenes.
IT ALL FALLS DOWN:
As you can see, fudging numbers with Disney+
may have just been the latest in a history
of bending the rules for Bob Chapek, but it
was the first time that he faced any real
consequences.
The SEC went ahead and fined Disney for I’m
just kidding, did you really think the SEC
would do anything?
Best case scenario, they might fine Disney
for $100 million or something.
The real consequences for Chapek were dealt
by the board and shareholders.
I don’t think the board cared too much about
the fudging of the numbers other than the
fact that that makes them look bad, but something
that they do care about is the bottom line.
And Chapek wasn’t able to deliver on the
bottomline.
In fact, he not only didn’t deliver, but
he put up some atrocious numbers which may
have been fudged to begin with.
So, in reality, these numbers are probably
worse than reported, but here’s what the
reported numbers suggest.
Right before, Chapek got fired, Disney+ reported
a loss of $1.5 billion in a single quarter.
To simply make up for Disney’s current burn
rate, Disney needs 62.5 million people to
join Disney+ and not watch anything at all
forever.
This may have sounded reasonable 2 years ago
when everyone was joining due to the pandemic,
but now, the exact opposite is happening.
In the most recent quarter, Disney+ reported
a subscriber loss of 2.4 million.
Last year, people were calling Netflix dead
for losing subscribers for the first time
in 10 years, and even that was only 500,000.
Disney+ over here is losing nearly 5 times
that amount after just being out for a mere
3 years.
Yeah, I don’t think it was very difficult
for the board to give Chapek the axe.
It just so happened to be exactly 999 days
after Chapek took over.
For Chapek, this was probably quite humiliating
and terrible for his reputation, but in terms
of compensation, it worked out quite well.
He was handed out a generous $20 million despite
driving Disney stock back to pandemic lows,
making Disney+ a money pit, and potentially
misleading investors for years.
In the meantime, Disney is looking to their
former CEO Bob Iger to work his magic once
again.
Iger was the one behind all the acquisitions
that Disney is known for today including Pixar,
Marvel, Lucasfilm, and 21st Century Fox.
So, Disney is hoping that Iger can pull off
a miracle with Disney+ as well, but only time
will till.
But, that’s the dark truth about Bob Chapek
and why he was really fired after just 999
as CEO.
Would you pay for Disney+?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you would like a $20
million severance.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.